we got a gamechanging surprise arrival
to Egghead this chapter one that I've
been desperately hoping for Luffy
returns as well we get more info on
kizaru's true allegiances and more so
make sure to stay tuned for that as we
are fast approaching the conclusion of
this insane Arc that much is obvious
after this chapter now CH pin within and
smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing one piece videos like this one I
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the Naka if you haven't
already by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece reviews and updates and
you're also helping us reach our
insanely close goal at this point of 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so if you'll
remember last time we had the alsoo
satisfying punch that Kuma delivered to
Saturn the punch that shook the world
alsoo satisfying not only because it was
a slave punching the man at the Pinnacle
of the world to use a bystander's words
but also because he was the man directly
responsible not only for Kuma becoming a
cyborg but also he caused Bonnie's
disease that made him agree to become a
cyborg in the first place this super
privileged and Powerful dude acted
horribly and caused Kuma and his loved
ones so much suffering that we needed
that punch for catharsis for emotional
relief and also for catharsis we needed
the follow-up moment of Bonnie hugging
Kuma and thanking him for everything now
that she saw the truth in his memories
and she knows that he did in fact write
those letters not going to lie I would
have been Furious if she never found
that out now of course that one punch
didn't finish off Saturn Kuma isn't Sy
after after all but Luffy was no longer
where he was laying as we saw last
chapter leading us to believe that he'll
be ready to fight Saturn soon Saturn
didn't stay down long and he even regrew
lost limbs there doesn't seem to be any
lasting damage Kuma's attack did however
free all the people who were frozen
though for whatever reason and so Sanji
can deflect Saturn's attack when he goes
after Bonnie and Kuma again and honestly
how cool is that that Sanji deflected a
Elder's attack kizaru joined in
attacking Frankie and in the last panel
Saturn said and I quote those who
studied the secrets of the world those
who possess the blood of a lost people
those who have awakened an ancient god
this island is full of inconvenient
people that must be eradicated end quote
he said this in the context of
activating the Buster call and deciding
to burn Egghead to the ground in the
name of justice as laughable as that
sounds but in 1984 Orwell showed how
governments take advantage of double
speak saying things like war is peace so
I guess we shouldn't be that shocked for
the elders clearly Injustice is Justice
now chapter
1,15 is called The Pinnacle of stupidity
and what a beautiful title for such an
intense and hype chapter we're told
Sanji sends off Bonnie at the vacuum
rocket and goes back to say Vega Punk so
it seems like Kuma's Final Stand which
we still can't fully explain how it
happened was a resounding success since
not only did he save Bonnie in that
moment he also freed Sanji from whatever
force was holding him Frozen and Sanji
went on to help Bonnie get to safety or
at least that's what it seems like right
now so that feels very gratifying from
Kuma's perspective the loving father
managed to save his daughter and we all
know that would be what's most important
to him Saturn then tells Vega Punk that
he ordered the destruction of egghead's
evacuation ship we saw something similar
at Ohara and the idea is to minimize
risks or Witnesses at all costs it's
very unfair but luckily this time as
we'll see we won't repeat history there
are now forces in the world who can
fight back against the world
government's injustices but more on that
exciting twist later the Marine
Battleship start shooting at egad
Saturn says he and kizu will remain
probably because they are the strongest
and also have the least chance of dying
Saturn at this point seems like he could
straight up be immortal and just
regenerate from everything and kizaru
could probably avoid most dangers and
piece out with his light Powers when
it's time now of course we will get to
kis again and what side he's truly on
for now though we cut T Nami Robin who
sleeping and Chopper they are all at the
back of the labo phase Brooke and Lilith
are preparing for the Escape moving the
Thousand Sunny by melting the clouds and
sliding A Thousand Sunny to the back
door so we see the early makings of the
Escape here Zoro for his part is still
fighting Luchi but we don't actually see
them this chapter I personally hope we
see Zoro deal with him or get the upper
hand in a big way before they're done
but either way we've shown progress as a
weaker Luffy fought him way back when
and now the first M Zoro can keep him
busy even though Luchi is now awakened
and much stronger than before it shows
clearly the progress the crew has made
as a whole and keep in mind Luchi has
been described as a genius and now he's
awakened so non-ap being able to deal
with him is really cool when you think
about it what I'm saying is we should
appreciate this moment and not just
write it off casually but the reason we
know Zoro still fighting him is because
jimbe goes where they are to break it up
and also my favorite part to make sure
Zoro isn't lost I love that it would be
hilarious if jimbe shows up and Luchi is
like there's no way Zoro is escaping and
jimbe was just like nah Zoro is going to
wreck you but I just need to make sure
that he doesn't get lost afterwards back
to Sanji now and I love getting more
from him after his latest hype power up
that allowed him to beat Queen with ease
that's right not a captain not a first
mate and yet still crushing an over 1
billion Barry opponent with ease
although he can't last he also has one
over the Elder for now because he
blocked his attack while Saturn didn't
really do anything to him yet so Sanji
is running back to VAP Punk and then
kizaru flies up and cuts the vacuum
rocket both Bonnie and Kuma fall and at
this point it is not looking good for
the kizaru joining the straw hats Theory
and him being the one that's save Luffy
I will hold out hope until the end a
little bit at least that he's just
trying to play the part until he can
turn on the Elder at the opportune time
but this is also different than just
kicking Frankie why couldn't he just let
the little girl escape safely rather
than putting her in danger again he
could have tried to do a little battle
with Sanji while letting her go and so
for that reason it's getting harder and
harder to believe that Kizer has
committed to the straw hats that's for
sure and believe me I'd like nothing
better than that twist because why
wouldn't the Sun God have the Admiral of
light on his crew if his character foil
Blackbeard can have one but it's not
looking good that must be acknowledged
at this point still I am waiting for
some kind of payoff for all of the
tension kizaru has been dealing with in
this Arc Saturn then orders all
pacifistas to shoot at them thinking how
pathetic it is that they will be killed
by Kuma's clones Saturn says this is the
Pinnacle of stupidity so get excited
because he just said the title of the
chapter in the chapter who saves Bonnie
and Kuma from the pacifista will now be
a big deal if kizaru is committed to
fighting alongside the Elder we need
someone else to intervene here and quick
Sanji won't be enough meaning Luffy
should be ready soon and we're actually
told in some spoilers that we do see
Luffy in the chapter near the food
making machine so he should be good to
go next chapter that's my guess he's
been eating a lot of food and he should
especially be up because kizu has
already been up for a while and Luffy
can't let himself be outclass by an
admiral at this point then we get to
easily the most high part of the chapter
we see the Marine Battleship that was
sent by Saturn to sink Eggheads EV
evacuation ship but the Marine
Battleship has been destroyed by an
unknown enemy a surviving Marine says
contact kizu at once we need to tell him
that they are heading to Egghead now
during chapter 179 we saw a ship with
Blackbeard's flag near Egghead but I
honestly don't think it's them that
they're talking about because that was a
long time ago at this point and why
would they want to help the innocent no
I've been saying for a while now that
this is the perfect time for Dragon to
show up and I'm feeling this could be it
they would obviously attacked the
Marines to save the innocent and after
all of the Dragon flashback stuff we got
recently after the bond between the
revolutionaries and especially dragon
with Kuma and with Kuma and his daughter
being here it just seems like it has to
be them at this point so just think of
that hype with the revolutionaries like
dragon and Sabo making it possible for
straw hats to escape writing the wrong
that they couldn't at Ohara when a
refugee ship was destroyed at this point
that would seem perfect and because of a
dragon and Luffy reunion it would be one
of the most hype twists so that's what
I'm thinking and hoping for and we know
Dragon helped Luffy before with smoker
and we saw him reaffirm how important
Luffy is to him in a recent flashback so
I think Luffy in this seemingly
impossible situation right now is a
prime candidate for some more Dragon
assistance and getting revenge for his
best bud Kuma would just be icing on top
of the cake for Dragon let me know your
thoughts though about this chapter and
who you think it is in the comments
we'll know next week who gets it right
because there's thankfully no break and
if you did enjoy this video you won't
want to miss my recent one about every
character's reaction to seeing Luffy's
gear five so far link on screen right
now like And subscribe to help us make
anime uproar history by hitting 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
I'll see you in the next one